jacques valade le ministre de la
recherche et de l'enseignement supérieur
présentait ce matin les grands objectifs
d'un plan sur l'avenir du supérieur
quatre grandes lignes dans ce projet
clément weill-raynal nous en donne
l'essentiel
première mesure préconisée la mise en
place d'un collège universitaire qui
regrouperait l'ensemble des premiers
cycles formations courtes à finalité
professionnelle et préparation aux
filières longues telles le dogue
objectif mettre fin à la sélection par
l'échec il faut savoir qu'actuellement
deux étudiants sur trois ne termine pas
leur premier cycle en ce qui concerne le
statut des établissements le ministre
suggère une autonomie plus grande des
universités un projet de loi définirait
le cadre général à l'intérieur duquel
chaque université mettrait en oeuvre
librement ses règles de fonctionnement
interne autonomie par exemple dans la
création des organes de direction ou
dans la gestion des fonds propres
autre suggestion la réforme du
recrutement et de la carrière des
enseignants
l'amélioration des qualités de vie de
l'étudiant reste que le projet de loi ne
sera présenté en conseil des ministres
au mois de mars
il a donc fort peu de chances d'être
voté avant l'élection présidentielle
je pose quelques principes qui sont
simples qui je crois sont accessibles à
tous
premier principe
tous les bacheliers doivent pouvoir
entrer dans l'université
ce n'est pas la section deuxième point
il n'est plus supportable que la
sélection se fasse par l'échec